All right. Tell me about the business.
>> I'm Dr. Zad Oasi, MD. I own Precision
Health Concierge Medicine. The business
was in business for 18 years before I
purchased. I've owned it for the past um
18 months.
>> Okay.
>> So, when we purchased, um revenue was
around 1.8 million. Um we've grown it to
3 million in the last 12 months. Profit
of 600K excluding my comp.
>> What comp do you take? Last year it was
about 300 and uh this year it'll be a
little bit more than that and then
three-year revenue goal of $15 million.
>> Cool. How do you get customers right
now?
>> Right now most of it well it used to be
mostly word of mouth and uh over the
past 4 months or so it's switched to
SEO.
>> Yeah. So originally um we had a rough
first year uh issues with the seller and
then issues with marketing. So, we knew
that marketing was uh our big
bottleneck. And so, we went out and uh
interviewed five and we hired one and uh
$50,000 later and no progress. We ended
up firing them. Um and I went on the
website, I did all this myself. Um SEO
turns out on the back end was trash. So,
when we finally found somebody to fix
it, um they started actually doing their
job and the SEO converted really well.
>> So, what's stopping right now from
scaling?
>> Uh it's mainly the the marketing piece.
um we're just not that good at it.
>> It is interesting um the $55,000 on the
bad agency and and what you were saying
earlier about like this [__]
Um it's funny cuz I see that and I just
think it's cost of doing business, you
know, like it's I wouldn't even
>> That was the lesson learned.
>> Yeah. But like and it also doesn't mean
agencies suck. Like the next one you
worked with it worked fine. It's just
like it's just part of the game. You're
it's just you have margin so that you
can try out a couple until one works.
What do you think is going to get in the
way of scaling for you?
The landscape is changing pretty quickly
and if we are not doing it correctly, it
can fall apart pretty quickly. The
technology aspect just from when we
started the technology has improved so
rapidly. If we don't do it properly,
every practice that we go into that we
don't do well could cost us months to,
you know, a year or whatever that is
when we're small and the competitors are
going to eat us up.
>> Okay.
>> Do you not agree?
I I'm all for having a lot of urgency. I
think people are going to keep getting
sick for a long time.
>> Yeah, of course.
>> Yeah. And I like if I were to bet on
industries, I think healthcare is fine.
Like which ones are going to get
disrupted? People going to have more
time to themselves. Uh and I think
there's also a a high-end component to
this which is like you're servicing
people who have money. And
you know I I think generic healthcare
will change a lot with AI, your GPS,
your general practitioners, etc.
>> People will always be willing to pay
more. There always will be a slice.
>> All right. Well, let's let's sit down
and figure out how to scale this thing.
>> The real reason I wanted to get into
this competition wasn't necessarily for
the money. Uh what I really wanted to do
was get the input from Alex because I
did do one of the scaling workshops and
within six months of identifying my
weaknesses, we have already accomplished
a lot of those things and now imagine
with what I know now with Alex's input
how far how much further that could take
me. That would be really awesome.
[music]
>> Okay. So [sighs and gasps] I I really
think there's call it three real things
to cover.
>> Mhm. And that's kind of it. All right.
So, the first is how can we speed up the
referral machine, right? And so, the
question is right now, what are you
doing? Obviously, you're getting word of
mouth, but what are you doing in order
to lubricate or facilitate it? Uh, so we
need to do more open houses. We did two.
Um, the one open house we offered
members a $500 credit for both the
member and the new signup. And then we
did some raffles, gave some people some
free stuff, so we introduced them to
some of the aesthetics. I love the
giveaway. Um, if you want to have like
way more people participate, just give a
year of the service away. Just a full
year of your optimized health, that
would be my grand prize. The second
place prize, um, and the way I'm
thinking about this is like we want you
want every referral to have a great
reason to tell a friend. For the
customers that you have, $500 probably
makes no difference, right? They're
probably going to refer you anyways. So,
and you just asking is what facilitated
it, but to like make it so that it's
social capital positive rather than
neutral. Um, I' it'd be better to do
either your friend gets some real
treatment, some actual thing that's like
a body optimization, whatever, or the
six-month supplement thing or that, or
uh you both get it as like if you if you
refer a friend, you get this treatment.
The the shtick is that it's a $1,000,
$2,000 type, I would say, type ticket.
Um but your cost on g way less than that
obviously. Um but the key is that if we
can it's it's just a way better reason
to come in.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. And the it's only for referrals.
So it's not like we're running that as
ads so you just have like you know Tom
Dick and Sally coming off the street who
are like oh I heard I got a coupon for
like that's not what you're looking for.
>> But it's like anybody who's an existing
like it could even be a perk to me kind
of like a like at kind of like at a gym.
Um you have uh like you can bring a plus
one that idea but like if you are call
it our you know you have our 5K
membership.
Um you you get five times our $2,000
one-off treatment or $1,000 one-off
treatment that you can give to your
friends uh and have them come in with
you to do it.
>> To me that's like a much more compelling
offer. Yeah.
>> And then what this does is that it
allows you that every touch point we can
ask them about it. So it's like we have
you have the immediate close, right? So
this is kind of point number one that
you can make it. So you you just closed
them. You're like, "Hey, by the way, um
a lot of people like to do some of these
treatments together because it's a lot
of fun." And so because you're now one
of these members, you're going to be
able to bring a friend with you at each
of these four instances.
>> And so whenever they book it, ask what
friend they want to bring.
>> You like that?
>> Yeah. It'd be a it'd be a great way
because our aesthetics business is
pretty much completely untapped and so
that would be a great way.
>> It's easy to do and like
>> and people who are investing in that
typically there's strong crossover.
>> Um
>> the second is when is there what wow
what moment are people like whoa like
you know what is that wow moment in the
patient journey?
>> Uh it's a little bit different for
everybody. Um, so like you know the
average 50-year-old guy who thinks he's
perfectly healthy and he comes back in
in four or five months and he's like,
"Dude, I haven't felt this good in
years." And I'm like, "Yeah, it's cuz
you didn't know you were feeling like
crap." Now that we've actually fixed all
these things or like
>> you know the 80-year-old patient who um,
you know, lost a bunch of muscle mass
and could barely walk and now that we've
used whatever treatments we have and
they're like, "Wow, you know, I actually
got my independence back." Do you do
love that do you do what cadence of of
touch points do you have with patients?
The older demographic usually starts out
at a at a much higher cadence at like 60
days and then 90 days and then we as we
optimize we kick it out and then um
younger people so uh like if you signed
up right you'd come in for your labs
you'd do your V2 max testing uh you'd do
your nutritional analysis and then 30
days later you show up you'd come in for
your 1 hour appointment with me
>> candy good on my nutrition analysis
>> 100% perfect for you I love that for you
>> so and that's the thing it's
personalized medicine right so you do
what you want um I just give you the
information.
>> Yep.
>> What I'm trying to identify by asking
the question is if there is a
universally they're going to feel much
better at day 90
>> and then get the referral,
>> right? So it's like maybe 90 because
it's it's
>> 90 days is a good spot. We have actually
already kind of solidified on that 90
days that we're going to start
implementing.
>> So we have one at our close. This is our
offer.
>> We have our 90-day. And for me, I would
want this to be a bam fam process.
meeting. Every one of these kind of
meetings, we we set the next one and
then we say, "Who do you want to bring
with you?" And so, it's almost like
assume that you're going to bring
someone with you every time because
that's how we do it. And we've also and
I'm sure there's tons of research you
could back it up that people who do
healthy things together are five times
more successful. Blah blah blah blah,
right? And so this is like this is
evidence backed, which it is. Uh when
you do things together, you will get way
better benefits. So like let's like I'm
doing this as a practitioner. This makes
sense.
>> Um
>> a lot of times that's how we get family
members. So wife signs up, we get
husband. Husband signs up, we get wife.
>> Yeah. So the third is you have a
newsletter, correct?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So what's the CTA inside of your
newsletter?
>> So we are uh we're very low pressure,
right? So we don't have calls to action.
I'm realizing now uh as as we're further
in it that I truly do now feel that our
product is so good that more people
should know about it. And so we're we're
not afraid to ask people. So, I have not
thought of putting a call to action in
the newsletter yet.
>> This is what I want you to do. [snorts]
>> PS,
>> perfect.
>> Very simple. It's very just it's it's
just it's not in your face. It's just
like PS. Um this quarter we're running a
uh uh you win a year of our premium VIP
service um from any of your friends and
family. And so if you want to enter and
anybody who enters automatically gets
that no matter what. To me, that's like
pretty compelling uh because they're
doing their friend a favor because
they're getting this no matter what, but
then the friend is really excited and uh
for this big giveaway. And the nice
thing with giveaways specifically is
that you can tell everybody what the
price is. So, there's no sticker shock
because when they come in and then we
offer like they come in, one person wins
the 20, but then everybody else you're
like, "Great, you can do the 5K or the
10K or whatever else." And I think you
doing the drawing at if you do that
raffle thing that you do like once a
quarter you do one of these to the list
that'll probably in and of itself
generate a lot of business.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Does that feel okay?
>> Good. Okay.
>> So this is kind of like the referral
referral engines. We needed a referral
offer which I think this feels feels
okay. This bam fam approach of like
you're going to get five of these call
it coupons. Not coupon. We wouldn't use
that word, but like uh every one of
these five treatments, you're going to
have the option of bringing somebody
else with you because of all the
evidence reasons I just said. So, who do
you want to bring with you next time?
Because now we're not asking for
referrals. We're just saying who do you
want to bring? It's just it's just much
easier.
>> Yeah. Okay. So, the second element of
this beyond the referrals, um walk me
through the sales process.
Now, since we have the sales uh the um
marketing person in house, uh she
handles all of the calls
>> and so she does her um script about what
our office is and then um she finds a
15-minute time on one of the physician
schedules.
>> So, there's a phone call first.
>> Mhm.
>> All right. And this is the marketing
girl takes this.
>> Yep.
>> All right. So, this is set. All right.
And then they come in person or they go
Zoom.
>> Uh for the most part, it's Zoom. I would
say about 10% come in person.
>> Interesting. Okay. And then the Zoom is
with the doc.
>> Uh well the Zoom is is with Hie. Uh the
>> marketing again.
>> Yep. Marketing.
>> So this is doc plus her.
>> Okay. Got it. Now what?
>> Uh they either sign up or they don't.
And so
>> on the call.
>> Yep. And so if they want to come in to
do a little bit more discovery,
>> they'll do they'll do a walk around with
Harley and then they'll decide whether
they want to sign up or not.
>> Got it. Um, so I get I call in, hey,
this I need my health to be not sucky.
Uh, she says, "Great. Let me see if I
can find a 15-minute slot on Dr. Zad's
calendar." And then she You see a
15-minute slot on your calendar. She
takes She hops on the Zoom. She says,
"Okay, let me go get him." She gets you,
you hop on, you say, "Hey, I think you
should buy some [__] from us." Uh, I'm
kidding. Uh, and then the person says,
"Yeah, that could be interesting." And
then you're like, hi will take care of
the rest of the the the business. And
then you hop off and then Harley closes
the sale.
>> Yeah. Effectively the what not
effectively that effectively why they
want to speak with the physician is
because they want to know what we're
going to do, right? Because what we're
doing is is a little bit different than
most other physicians. And so they want
to take the time to understand if we
actually do what we say we do. And so
it's kind of building confidence for the
patient like, hey, we're going to do all
these things and we know what we're
doing.
>> Okay, great. So after that they then
come in person.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So they get onboarded in person
and then at this visit that's all
onboarding. Do they get any treatment?
>> So uh what we do is we have instructions
for fasting labs. Um based on that first
call we've analyzed uh what type of labs
we want to run with them.
>> So we do labs here.
>> Mhm. Okay. Got it. And then
>> then they have a in-person meeting with
the physician 30 days later.
>> Got it. So, to me, this looks like a
warm process, not a cold process. Uh,
cuz someone just getting on the phone,
having a phone call, and then 15 minutes
to 10K a year,
they've got to know something about you
most likely in order to make that
purchase here. Um,
this will work for the style that you
are doing right now. The close rates are
fine. like if you were running meta ads
um or search ads, it would be it would
be unlikely that that we'd need to put
more friction in the process. Yeah. In
order for this to work,
>> but I'm not necessarily sure that that
would be my immediate recommendation.
And so if we're looking at the demand
side of the business
>> further this way, um I think
basically you should probably have an
event-based
marketing strategy.
>> Mhm. rather than adsp space. Not to be
clear, not that adspace doesn't work. It
does. I'll give you I'll give you two
adjacent strategies that you can do in
sequence rather than a true like I like
rather than what I would consider to be
a traditional like call funnel, which I
don't think is the strategy here.
>> So number one is you did one event,
right? And it was honestly lackluster in
your ability to do the main thing that
would have mattered for the event,
right? And so like I think there's a
world where you could have spent $10,000
and made like 400 instead of whatever
you made 70, right? So in that world
it's like how can we do one a week?
>> Yeah.
>> No, I guess that's that's really my
question is like is there anything that
prevents you from doing one of these per
week because there's for sure events.
You're in a big enough city. You're in
um Sarasota.
>> There's probably a health or wealth or
business related event.
>> Yes. every week for sure and probably
more. And so I would take that as my
primary kind of like paid strategy is
you bring the big machine that you got
and you do the expensive scan which is
normally $500. I know what is it
normally?
>> So uh realistically we could do like 150
bucks.
>> Okay.
>> There actually uh there is another
machine that we're going to buy that
people are literally driving across the
state and people do pay $500 to $1,000
to use that machine. Is it something
that people would get more than once?
>> Oh, yeah. You do it every six months,
especially once we put you on treatment
to analyze.
>> Okay. So, then I would say I would still
do a giveaway at the event, which is a
year
>> of scans, right? And I'm trying to think
like maybe call it like a year of
digital health cuz normally it's a year
of scans, right? So, it's like a year of
integrated health. Same big idea of
giveaway. And I just wouldn't be afraid
of like
>> this is marketing. We have to be willing
to give things away. Um, and know our
math. the first time you do it, you're
afraid of that you're going to give one
client away, but you got 475 patients.
It's not going to make a difference to
the business. And so, it's like I would
be wanting to give away the 20K thing
because what's that going to do? I get
to talk about it to everybody, but it's
like it's not a it's not a it's not a
pressury sale. I'm like, this is what we
do for our VIP. Enter here. In the
meantime, go get a scan right now.
You're going to have a line. That's what
I want. I think what I would do is I
would have my scan is I would have
people watch a VSSL and set an
appointment for later that day for a
close. You just have you need some
separation. So if there's any is there
any part of this process where there's
some kind of baked in 5 to 7 minute wait
at some point.
>> Uh the scan itself will take 20 minutes.
>> Okay. Can they watch something while
they're getting scanned?
>> That's true. Yes.
>> Okay. Great. So we do scan plus VSSL at
the same time so that they understand
what's going on but the whole time
they're being sold. And then right
afterwards you can have those close
meetings. You'll know immediately if it
feels too fast. If it does feel too fast
I would just set the next appointment
and add a VSSL in between. That would be
it. So like V1 test is scan plus VSSL
straight to close. The V2 of the test if
for some like you'll get a vibe if
you're like people feel like this is too
fast. Then V2 is um scan plus VSSL and
then we do appointment as our next
meeting and then before they have the
appointment you the VSSL and then you
close.
It's still two appointments. I'm just
saying you may schedule it here.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So
I would just say like can we do one of
these per week and from a scaling this
perspective
every practice that you have you can
there's going to be events that going to
have high net worth individuals that are
older that are going to be attending and
it doesn't really matter like you could
go to a cigar but maybe they [laughter]
might have I mean hey there's people who
like cigars who also still want to be
healthy.
>> We could 100% we could bring in a um
>> like a breathing. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
Um, so I think this would be my this
would be my strategy. Big giveaway.
Everybody gets a scan. While they're
watching the scan, uh, we then set them
up for a close. If not, we schedule and
then and then meet up the next day or we
can do Zoom afterwards. Either way, but
this is going to be monster lead genen
at the events. The second, which is the
even more scalable version of this,
which honestly you could probably do
this and get to your 15 million. Um,
which I like hesitate to even bring up
more, but we're doing it for the people
at home. Um, I would like you said you
have a partner that's in wealth
financial advisor stuff. So, one of the
most common for like a high trust sale
in-person events and workshops work
better than just about anything.
>> Yeah.
>> And so, you could do a one-day full
health thing that includes this scan um
and maybe one other thing that's baked
into the ticket. Um, and then you just
talk about your stuff and it could be a
half day. It doesn't really matter. It's
kind of like the diabetic dinners. You
might have heard of that that kind of
world. Um, it's the same idea. And then
I would probably meet with them in
person to close.
>> Yeah.
>> Because you have uh and so your lead
genen is basically
ads. So this is where this is where like
meta this is where a meta ad campaign
would be like more valuable, but you're
going to have to sift through the the
crap, but you also have the ocean to go
after. So that's a bit of the trade. Um,
but I'll just walk through this, but
this is for sure what I would start with
on the demand side. So we run meta ads.
It goes to the uh one day
uh workshop.
Name it whatever you want. One day
workshop uh with the you know
you know $500 in scans, whatever. Um you
can charge money for it. You can have it
be free.
It's probably better to charge something
for it. Make it $99 just so you get a
little bit of riff ref. You also have a
card on file which makes the clothes
easier. Um, and then from there then I
would just book all the inersons
and then at the in person and then Hie
does the close and between here they
watch a VSSL before they come in. So
it's basically ads uh pitch one schedule
pitch two with VSSL in between. So if
we're looking at big picture what this
hits overall
the big meta thing is the attraction
offer that you're going to use as a
giveaway. That's going to be to get
referrals and then the BAM fam book a
meeting from meeting every time that
they have their treatment we should ask
them who they want to bring and that's
one of the big benefits and then we peel
them off and we run the sales process
because they're going to be warm anyways
the existing process will work
newsletter add we add our PS and then we
uh add our our 90-day you know
checkpoint as well but I still think
this is going to do the majority of the
work which is every single time they
have a meeting ask who they're bringing
with them and that's one of the main
benefits of working with us now you
can't bring the same person twice
>> but you You can bring anyone you want
cuz the marginal cost is nothing and if
you can convert [__] a third like who
cares, right? Um sales process I'm not
going to mess with. This is what I think
is going to be the big thing on the
demand gen side. Um and you already know
how to do this. Uh and so it's really
just how many events can we do? And so I
would just challenge you to be like can
we do one a week? You'll close a year's
worth of income every every event.
>> I mean that would be incredible.
>> Yeah. I mean, if you have a 300 person
event, you could probably with that kind
of offer get scans on a third of the
people there, get a 100 scans. If you
convert 25% of people who get scans, 25
sales.
>> Yeah, it'd be nuts,
>> right? It's two and a half million event
in LTV.
>> Yeah, it'd be nuts.
>> Who cares? And to be fair, what I'm
seeing, because I look at a lot of
businesses, the people who are running
this model are printing right now. And
so, the numbers are insane.
>> Yeah.
>> And you have unsophisticated business
owners, which healthare professionals
tend to be, um, even the entrepreneurial
ones. And it's just cuz like most of
them, the reason I laugh at the $55,000
thing is it's like there's a curse of
being a physician and I know this having
three physicians in my family um is that
because you started in business trading
your time in the beginning. There's a
tendency to like think in small numbers.
And there's a reason that like not many
physicians actually scale their
practices. Like by number of physicians
versus scaled practices, it's a crazy
ratio compared to almost any other
business. Um, and so there's this trap
of making a lot of money but not so much
money that's like enough money to be
comfortable like golden handcuffs. And
so they tend to be very riskaverse
because also the type person who gets
into medicine tends to tends to not
always but is very riskaverse.
>> Um, there's also the world of defensive
medicine and all that I want to get
into. Um, but all that to say it's like
that 55 grand, who gives a [__] right?
And then betting on this uh, you know,
$10,000 it's like they want $50,000 for
this event. It's like yeah, but if we do
a million bucks, who gives a [__] And
we might do one and it might not work,
but it's like this is the game and all
we got to do is find one event and then
after we have that one event, we just
know from every year here going forward,
you're now in our permanent event
calendar. And so the goal is we just get
we try out event try event and then it's
like every other every third becomes a a
humdinger and you're like great this is
permanently in the calendar and every
year we reach back out say hey let's be
a platinum sponsor whatever and then
that becomes the marketing cadence and
then you're going to hit capacity really
fast.
>> Yeah,
>> that would be the game that I would
play.
>> I agree.
feel good.
>> Great.
>> Any questions about that?
>> No, it's uh I like I like this idea
because um it's it's kind of the way we
were going, but um this is a better way
to do it,
>> right?
>> So, yeah, that's what I would do to
scale this thing.
>> Thank you,
>> J. Appreciate it.
>> Yeah. Easy.
[music]
>> All right. Let's look at the scaling
road map. Let's see. Let's see where the
the practice is at right now. You're
doing 3 million, right? How many people
work at the practice right now?
>> 16.
>> 16. Okay. So, you're you're going to be
in this phase into this phase. So, the
productized to optimize phase. So, 10 to
19. You're in like kind of the director.
I don't know what your your title is,
but it's probably medical director or
something like that.
>> Or is it CEO?
>> I'm the CEO. That's right. Chief Zed,
>> Lord, Lord of Lords.
>> Lord AI. I kind of don't have um a true
title right now. Basically, the other
founding partner, he is he's the medical
director. Um, so I'm kind of in this
weird phase where I'm almost still part
of the business, but I'm not. And so I'm
trying to figure out what that, you
know, role actually is. But essentially,
my goal is to try to help grow the
business.
>> Cool. So if we're looking at this, this
is where you're at to graduate into the
next level. So I'll just walk through
this really quickly. Um, but right now
you're in the process of having this
kind of supplementation and the
aesthetics angle. And so like that's
what you're building into increase LTP
right now, right? That's thing one from
the um spending more niche down
messaging with new offer. So for us, the
new offer is going to be that giveaway.
>> Mhm.
>> Right. Um and that's that's basically
the play here. Now the sales ads
material, you're in process for the
VSSL,
>> right? And basically building out this
sales motion. Sorry, the sales motion um
that we just went over. That's kind of
like what we need to go what we need to
do to graduate from here. And then the
the the CS playbook, the onboarding is
this bam bam referral process where it's
like, okay, bring a friend every single
time. And that's the that's the game
that we're going to do to increase LTV
on the back end. Now, from like what are
the problems that are about to hit,
right? Um quality is going to start
becoming an issue as you get more and
more patients, especially as you get
this this machine turned on and then
you're going to have new new docs in
that aren't as experienced, don't know
you as well, etc. And so it's like how
do we have incremental product
improvements? um for the customer
roadmap that we're on. The uh you
probably won't need to worry about the
ad assembly because we're going to be
doing um basically event- based
marketing for now. So, it's really just
reachouts is all we have to do there.
But sales training is going to become a
bigger issue at these events. And so,
it's like we're going to have to get
better and better and more systemized at
the sales training. Also means that like
you're going to have to like coach Hi,
might have to coach other people to do
it because there might be a world where
you're doing two events a week or three
events a week, right? Um, and then, uh,
I'm going to bet because you're at, you
know, almost 500 customers. When you're
at 1500, you're going to see that
there's some clear cohort cohorts. Yeah.
>> Um, and we covered some of this
activation with that 30 and 90. Um, but
there's probably going to be a customer
in there that's willing to pay 50 or
100,000 a year.
>> Yeah.
>> And we want to give them the opportunity
to do that, right? And so, we don't need
to worry about that now, but that's like
what's coming around the corner. And so,
that's where you're at in the scaling
road map. And for anyone who's at home,
welcome to download this for free. Just
type in information. I'll tell you where
you're at. There's 90 90-minute video
that tells you what to do. Okay. So, I'm
going to simplify this cuz we talked
about a lot, but I want to like
every person who comes in, we need to
ask them who they're bringing with them
for their each treatment
to your list. We're doing giveaway once
a quarter, which in this 90-day period
that we're talking about, this has to
happen.
>> Yep.
And you need to get really violent with
how many how many events are coming up
that you can attend and run this play.
Let's say, do you have kids?
>> No.
>> Okay. Do you have a wife?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Let's say your wife gets napped.
Unless you do a certain amount of
events. How many events do you think you
can do between now and 90 days from now?
I'm being dead serious.
>> I would do 90.
>> You do 90
>> if if if that were the
>> How about Well, then can you do 12?
>> Realistically, what we were planning was
one per month.
>> Okay. I would just like to say let's do
one a week
>> and yolo it.
>> We will try.
>> Your wife's gonna get napped.
>> We will do it.
>> Okay, great. [laughter]
>> Okay. Well, I just want to see a world
where we do 200, 300, 400k from 10
events over the next quarter.
>> That'd be fantastic.
>> And you do 4 million and then you're
already pacing your I mean plus your
three, right? You're you're you're
already pacing your at least, you know,
10 million plus by the end of the year
minimum.
>> That would be nuts.
or awesome
>> or awesome. Cool. Let's do it. [music]
>> So, overall, I I'm a little bit biased
because I I was raised in in healthcare.
Ironically, I don't talk about it much,
but I was raised in healthcare uh with
both parents as physicians. Um
I really like healthcare in an AI world.
I also really like healthcare because
the there's so much lowhanging
opportunity that exists in the
marketplace right now and I don't think
the demand's going anywhere and from a
macro marketplace perspective all the
people who have money are getting old
and there's way few we're not making as
many people um and the people who have
it don't want to die and so and they got
the money to try and prevent it and so
this part is booming so there's a huge
supply constraint issue number one
number two the people you're competing
against are either massive or tiny and
there's not a lot in the middle and
that's very exciting three traditional
call it um marketing and sales motions
and done classy not shittily um unlock
like not just like 20% or 30%
incremental improvements but can be like
10x 20x improvements in the business
like very short periods of time.
I think that you will be able to do this
and I think that from a revenue
perspective of the businesses that I
looked at today, this will probably be
the one that I think can generate the
most money in the shortest period of
time and also has a model that uh can be
replicated. So like this event-based
motion
guys a white lab coat you run the scan
it's like very straightforward and the
LTV on this because no one is really
doing it. It's still crazy. um maybe in
the next 20 years it'll start coming
down and all that stuff will happen. But
we're so far away from that. Um that
this excites me. And so uh on the on the
that's on the scale side. On the fail
side um the things that worry me is is
uh it I don't I don't feel a huge amount
of marketing chops. Obviously there's
but like I don't know how. Um and great
Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> um and to grow the business. I'm I'm a
big believer and one of the hardest
parts for physicians is that they
typically make enough, like I said
earlier, that they don't want to invest
more in their education cuz they were
like, I did enough education, but it's
still like a totally different game. Um
and they usually don't want to they're
afraid of marketing, they're afraid of
selling, they're afraid of seeming a
certain way. Um a bunch of mental blocks
around pricing because then they have
this whole like I'm I'm trying to do
good, but then I don't want to. It it
becomes this whole mess. And so that's
usually where where docs fail. They also
tend to hold on to things too close and
say no one can do it like I can do it.
There's also usually a lot of ego. I'm
mixed on you. I'm not sure uh on that
side. Um but that is usually a huge
issue when I'm dealing specifically with
physicians. Surgeons are even worse. Um
I come with both parents being surgeons.
Uh [laughter]
anyways um all that to say uh I think
this plan will succeed and then if we're
looking at the next 90 days of scale or
fail, we are scaling. So, I'll see you
back in 90. Will you do 10?
>> Yeah, for sure.
>> Just do this, dude. If you just do this.
>> Yeah. Thank you.
>> All right. Rock and roll.
>> The conversation really helped me to
solidify our plan. And it's it's really
cool when somebody um gives you advice
and you're on that track. And so, I
really want to try to um open up the
different opportunities that can come
from what we talked about. So, we had
eight business owners out and they are
all competing for $100,000 and working
with me for a year. to scale their
businesses. And so that was scale or
fail. We'll see you next time.
>> All right, guys. Dr. Z here, Precision
Health Concier in Sarasota. Little
update uh since we filmed. So, I'm way
off schedule. Never going to achieve
what Alex gave me to do. And I'll tell
you why. Sarasota is very seasonal. We
shut down from May to September. Half
the population leaves. And so, I quickly
realized I was going to struggle to find
the right events. Alex had said, "Don't
make your own events because that's two
steps ahead." Well, it's exactly what I
did. And now we have an entire lecture
series set up with a couple of venues
that um are where our ideal clients
live. And so this is actually a great
thing for us because people after seeing
me on the um as one of the contestants
on Scale or Fail are now actually
reaching out to me and which is exactly
what I've wanted because I want to help
physicians deliver this level of health
care all over the country. So, I think
it's all been a big win and and we'll
move forward and be successful.